mid winter in the farthest reaches of
northeastern Greece gale force winds and
bitter cold in this vast barely
inhabited wilderness there are plenty of
places to hide but break cover and you
risk everything at the hospital mortuary
is evidence of the risk sisters from
Somalia who froze to death in each
other's arms to among dozens who
recently perished many more though have
been killed in car accidents as the
police have tried to chase down the
smugglers
heaven 70 people in one car we have car
accident that seven of them and ten
people who wouldn't how do they hide
seventeen people in a car I don't know
the more hostile Europe becomes the
better business gets for the smugglers
on the evros River the border between
Turkey and Greece they're using the same
big rubber boats that take people over
the sea on land fleets of vehicles
seized by the police tell a story of the
increasing industrialization of illegal
migration into the European Union where
there one airport or silversmith on us
the south on the training migrants to be
guides they leave cars on the hills for
them and tell one of the migrants to be
the driver some of them are children and
don't even know how to drive properly
refugees are guided to deserted
buildings sleeping in the rat droppings
with the windows open to escape if the
army arrives locals film them as they
pass in small groups but barely a word
is spoken Europe has become a hostile
environment for asylum seekers and these
are the consequences if they made it
this far no still alive it means they've
dodged the Greek police and military and
followed the smugglers instructions
stayed off the roads
stayed on the tracks but it's at least
another 100 kilometers from here to any
form of civilization several hundred
more until they get to the border with
North Macedonia naziha who come all the
way
Afghanistan made it through the
wilderness did anybody help you know
nobody can help us when we fall down
when we have injuries in our body not
and nobody can help us we just help
ourself that's it
thousands are still coming across the
success of the smugglers and difficulty
for the police in covering vast areas
means far more people get through than
die they're out there somewhere
lawrence lee al jazeera northeastern
greece